[Music]
who's there whispered in the dark this
question begins a tale of conspiracy
deception and moral ambiguity and in a
play where everyone has something to
hide its answer is far from simple
written by William Shakespeare between
$15.99 and 1601 Hamlet depicts its
titular character haunted by the past
but immobilized by the future mere
months after the sudden death of his
father Hamlet returns from school a
stranger to his own home and deeply
unsure of what might be lurking in the
shadows but his brooding takes a turn
when he's visited by a ghost that bears
his father's face the phantom claims to
be the victim of a murder most foul and
convinces Hamlet that his uncle Claudius
usurped the throne and stole Queen
Gertrude Hart the princes morning turns
to rage and he begins to plot his
revenge on the new king and his court of
conspirators the play is an odd sort of
tragedy lacking either the abrupt
brutality or all-consuming romance that
characterized Shakespeare's other work
in the genre
instead it plumbs the depths of its
protagonists indecisiveness and the
tragic consequences thereof the ghosts
revelation draws Hamlet into multiple
dilemmas what should he do who can he
trust and what role might he play in the
course of justice these questions are
complicated by a tangled web of
characters forcing Hamlet to negotiate
friends family court counselors and love
interests many of whom possess ulterior
motives the Prince constantly delays and
dinners over how to relate to others and
how he should carry out revenge
this can make Hamlet more than little
exasperated but it also makes him one of
the most human characters Shakespeare
ever created rather than rushing into
things Hamlet becomes consumed with the
awful machinations of thinking itself
and over the course of the play his
endless questions come to echo
throughout our own racing lines to
accomplish this Shakespeare employs his
most introspective language from the
usurping kings blazing contemplation of
heaven and hell to the princes own
cackling meditation on mortality
Shakespeare uses melancholic monologues
to breathtaking effect this is perhaps
best exemplified in Hamlet's most famous
declaration of angst to be or not to be
that is the question whether tis nobler
in the mind to suffer the slings and
arrows of outrageous fortune
or to take arms against a sea of
troubles
and by opposing end them this monologue
personifies Hamlet's existential dilemma
being torn between thought and action
unable to choose between life and death
but his endless questioning raises yet
another anxiety is Hamlet's madness part
of a performance to confuse his enemies
or are we watching a character on the
brink of insanity these questions weigh
heavily on Hamlet's interactions with
every character and since he spends much
of the play facing inward he often fails
to see the destruction left in his wake
he's particularly cruel to Ophelia his
doomed love interest who was brought to
madness by the princes erratic behavior
her fate is one example of how tragedy
could have been easily avoided and shows
the ripple effect of Hamlet's toxic mind
games similar warning signs of tragedy
are constantly overlooked throughout the
play sometimes these oversights occur
because of willful blindness such as
when Afilias father dismisses Hamlet's
alarming actions as mere love sickness
at other points tragedy stems from
deliberate duplicity as when a case of
mistaken identity leads to yet more
bloodshed these moments leave us with
the uncomfortable knowledge that tragedy
evolves from human error even if our
mistake is to leave things undecided for
all these reasons perhaps the one thing
we never doubt is Hamlet's humanity but
we must constantly grapple with who the
real Hamlet might be is he a noble son
avenging his father or a mad Prince
creating courtly chaos should he act or
observe doubt or trust who is he why is
he here and who's out there waiting in
the dark
here's a question for you do you prefer
Shakespeare's comedies or his tragedies
register your vote by clicking one of
these videos
[Music]